(audience applauding)
- Y'all look fabulous.
- Hi!
- Good to see you
- Oh my gosh,
you look fabulous.
- You look fabulous.
- So how long have y'all been in New York?
I just got here. I love it.
- Oh yeah, I heard you moved.
- How long have you,
you're born and raised, right?
- Born and raised.
- Yeah. Never could leave.
I tried a few times, but yeah,
I always found myself back.
- Yeah, you always come back.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, I've been here for a while.
I'm telling you, everyone
comes to New York
for six months and then they never leave.
- Yeah.
- Yeah, it's pretty great.
- So, you're here to stay.
- What's better than New York?
Yeah, it is pretty great.
And I'm a total southern girl,
so I never thought I'd say that,
but I actually love it.
And like, wherever you live is kind
of your own little small village,
like your own small town, like of stuff.
I love it.
- It's so true.
- Yeah.
- And people are like,
well, this area's better.
And I like this one more.
And they're like battles.
- They're all great.
Yeah, but why do you
choose to do the show?
Do you feel like it's exciting to do that?
Or do you get a little nervous
being a part of a show like this?
'Cause everybody's in your life.
- I don't think we knew
what we were getting into.
- Oh, that's, that's how they got you.
- Yeah, I took a job.
- Yeah. (laughs)
(audience laughing)
- She's a model.
- I was like, yep, I'll do it.
- I was like, you know,
it's just another job,
- Yeah.
- but I really didn't know
what I was sign up.
- It's really not, like it's real life.
- But it's good because we
learn a lot about each other
and learn about ourselves,
and I don't know,
I think it's a good
platform for women, right?
We get our own business, we
get to say what we wanna say.
I think our relationship might kind
of help other people, other girls.
So for that, I think it has, you know,
- Benefits.
- benefit to it.
And I mean, I also feel like I come from
a culture that is really private.
Women can talk like, you
know, the whole thing.
So me being in New York,
and getting this kind of opportunity,
"I'm like, hmm, I should not not take it."
- Yeah.
- I think it's just,
it's great like having, as
a woman, having a platform.
- It's a solid point.
I've never really thought about that.
Not many women all over the
world get to have that choice.
- To get what we get to do.
- Yeah.
- Like, it's, it's a very-
- It's an amazing, and,
I think also, like, we're all girls.
Girls, most of us at least.
And I think we,
(all laugh)
- There's so much there with
what you just said. (laughs)
- Sorry. Whoops.
A little bit of shade.
- She's a Cancer,
she just can help it.
(audience laughs)
- You know what though?
It's really entertaining. (laughs)
Yeah.
- No, but you know, it's like a sisterhood
that we've all formed.
- Yeah.
- And it's unbreakable,
because we've, no one else
will understand what we
- You go through.
- all went through together.
You know what I mean? So.
- Yeah.
- I feel like they threw us
in like Serengeti at night
and said, "Figure out how to get out."
(audience laughs)
And she was just like,
"Listen, am I not, you're my,
your cup of tea, but you gonna
help me get out of here."
- Yeah.
- It's like we are the
only people can really
understand what is happening
and what's going on.
And it keeps us closer,
but also being close with someone that
also can bring a lot of-
- Yeah, the closeness
actually can turn on you,
because you get so close.
You're like, "Why did you do that to me?"
- You get hurt more.
- Yeah.
- Which is just
happens in friendship.
- Yeah.
- In a way they're like,
"You are so close to me,
you should know."
Right?
- Right.
- Yeah.
- So it's like,
"No, sometime you just
have to communicate."
And that goes across
everyone in this world.
- Yeah.
- Like people don't,
a lot of husband and wife
are fighting for this.
Like, he should just know we've
been together for so long.
- Right, that's a good point. I like that.
- Like, he's not, he's not God.
He doesn't, you have to really articulate
your feelings for people, you know?
And you'll be very clear,
and don't do it when you're angry
because then nobody can hear it.
- Oh, I'm the person I have to go,
"Ooh, I need a minute."
I'm gonna be on my own.
- Same.
- I can't do it like right in the moment.
Which bothers people.
- I know. I know.
- Because you have boundaries.
- Yeah, well it bothers people though,
'cause they don't want, they're like,
"No, we need to remedy it right now."
And I'm like, "I know, but I'm
not in a good frame of mind."
So you have to respect that part. Yeah.
- But did you, were you like always
or did you learn?
- Because when you walk away-
- Oh, lots of therapy, Ubah, yes.
(all laughing)
Like lots of therapy, yes.
I was not into confrontation.
- Raise your hand if
you go into therapist.
- Hey!
(audience yelling)
- I think therapy's like a privilege.
Like if you do it-
- It's a privilege.
- Like, you know, what a lucky thing
to be able to do.
- God, I grew up
around people being like,
go write about it or
something nobody cares.
Like, you know what I'm saying?
- Yeah.
- Like, it's like
when you're poor, nobody
has that luxury, you know?
- Such a luxury.
- But to have a trained professional go,
"Hey, this is maybe how you should
navigate this or whatever."
- Right.
- But yeah, knowing how to,
"Hey, I don't deal well
in that situation."
It's like, to walk away for a minute,
but I guess the producers
on your show are like,
"Don't walk away."
- Don't walk away
- Sit in it.
- No, actually-
- I did some walking.
- Marinate.
- Honestly,
they don't tell us.
- Oh.
- No, they don't. They don't.
- You can do whatever you wanna do.
I can close the door and go to sleep.
I can take this out if I want to.
They will film you, but they
don't tell you what to do.
- Oh, I like the power in that though.
- Yeah, yeah.
- This is coming off,
this is, yeah.
- Yeah.
- But you are so in the
heat, you don't want to.
- Yeah.
- Once you're in a mess you're like,
"I'm already in a mess
anyways, let's do this."
- (laughs) I love you.
- You know so.
- Well this is the first time
in "Real Housewives" history
that the show recast an entire city.
So we had Ubah and Erin's castmate,
Jenna Lyons on the show a few weeks back,
and she had this to say
about the new season.
- I think what's nice
about this season is that
everyone has somebody
different to kind of plug into.
We're all pretty different.
Like, you know.
- Yeah, but that's
what makes the show cool.
- It's much more diverse.
I think between age and
ethnicity and background and age.
I'm the old one.
- Yeah.
(Ubah and Erin clapping)
(audience clapping)
She does not look old.
I'm like, "What?"
Do you agree with that though?
Like the new season having
better representation
just across the board?
- Absolutely.
- I think even in terms of
- We're so different.
- geographic.
Like where we live.
- Even where we live is different.
- Yeah.
I think we're really, it's
such a different thing.
It's such a different, I don't even think
you can compare.
- Which they kind of
had to do if you're gonna
completely, you know,
do a re-haul of it,
- Yeah.
- and have new, I think that's cooler.
- Yeah. No, yeah. It's
really not the same.
- I mean even our professions,
like they're all so different.
We don't all do the same thing.
- I know, I wanna get into that.
I'm gonna get into that.
(audience clapping)
So, y'all had conflict
at one point, right?
But you're good now?
Well, you seem good now.
Or you're either really good actors.
- Are we good actors?
- Yeah.
- We're like horrible actors.
- No, I swear to God
we will not do that to you guys to come.
I'm not, I don't do fake.
- No, me neither.
- Oh my God.
- It gets me in trouble. (claps)
(audience applauding)
- It's exhausting.
- Yeah, yeah.
- To have to pretend.
- I think that's something I
need to learn going forward.
Like being in the public eye sometime
you can't say everything you mean.
- Yeah.
- Because-
- I would like
to be more fake.
- Yeah. (laughs)
- It's just difficult for me.
- Yeah, yeah, yeah.
I think our fight was very real.
- Yeah.
- And it was
huge misunderstanding.
- Yeah.
- In a both side.
And unfortunately none
of you guys will ever
see the six hours of filming of that.
- Oh.
- 'Cause you know,
they cannot show you guys everything.
So they show what they wanna show.
And let's face it, if they
don't leave you guys question
or calling one of us is bad or is not.
- Then what's gonna bring
him back to like, yeah.
- Then what is, there's
no next season, right?
- Yeah.
- So, I am learning that.
- Well, you're like a producer.
- To accept it.
- Yeah.
- I'm learning. Trust me.
- Very insightful.
- I know, I was like, that's more like
how a producer thinks.
- It's been a hard battle.
- Yeah.
No, because what's, you are very private
with like your personal life.
- Yes.
- And you're pretty open.
Right?
- I'm way too open and my
husband is way too open.
I'm like, we're not gonna talk about
everything next time because
- Yeah.
- what has been shown
- That's what you say.
- is our entire sex life.
- Oh.
- Which is great.
- Hey, but that's
not a problem.
Congratulations.
(all clapping)
- That's hysterical.
No one has ever said that, I love it.
- Yeah, well not everybody's
having that life right now.
So you're, back to you.
So you're very private
about it though, right?
You're like-
- So here's the thing, I'm not private,
I have never been private
of my relationship.
I love to flaunt my men's.
I love it.
- Yeah.
- 'Cause I usually get
them hot, smart, and rich.
- Oh yeah. (claps)
(audience cheering and clapping)
All right!
- I love it.
- Yeah.
- I love it. Yeah.
- You know, women wear jewelry
and we usually have, you
are what you're extended
of the person next to you, right?
- Yeah.
- This is why I tell guys,
"I'm like, I don't know why
they're so afraid of getting married.
You are literally getting
a built in concierge."
(Kelly laughs)
Your wife is like 24 hours concierge.
- No opposite.
- No?
- He's my concierge.
- Well, for you in your relationship,
but most women, they're
the one who taking care
of their wife, what to wear, what to eat.
Married men have a better life.
- It's why some of us are divorced.
But yes.
- Yeah.
That single man.
- (laughs) No, I'm with you.
How is it, speaking of family
though, how is your mom doing?
She has health concerns right now, right?
- Yes, so I haven't
really said this anywhere
and I don't want to get choked up.
I'm, she's okay with me talking about it.
But she had breast cancer this summer.
- Yeah.
That's hard.
- And it's hard because she's
like my strong family member,
like my healthy strong,
nothing ever happens to her.
So it really threw me for a loop.
And it was just a lot.
But thank God, I mean the amount of change
that's happened in this world,
I mean in terms of health and-
- Medically speaking.
- and yeah,
I'm like, I get choked up
so I start thinking loopy.
Like you.
- Yeah, yeah.
- Sick, well like as I'm sick,
but no, she is okay, thank God.
She's on an amazing
medication that actually
shrunk the tumor in half in six months.
- Wow.
- I mean, it's unbelievable.
She didn't even have to do chemo, so.
- Wow.
- Yeah.
- Well, good for your mom.
(all clapping)
So happy for her, yeah.
- So happy. Thank God.
- And you, did your father,
and your father passed away,
and then your mother right after, right?
- Yeah.
- That's hard.
- [Erin] Very hard.
- [Kelly] Did you,
and you were really close
with your mom, I heard.
- Yeah.
- So like did she ever
leave you with any advice
that you still just keep around with you?
- Well, my mom, I always, I call
and complain all the
time about everything.
This person cut me off.
This person did this. (chuckles)
She always said to me,
"You don't know what you,
you don't know what you
neighbor is going through."
- Yeah.
- And I keep saying,
"My neighbor are rich, they're okay."
(all laughing)
- They don't go through (beep).
And she's like, "You don't know what
your neighbor are going through."
Like you, so what she meant is like,
you never know the next
person in the subway or out,
you know what they're going through.
- Yeah.
- So true.
- Like nobody walk around
with their information, right?
- Yeah.
- So she's just like,
"Say, you know, you need to be grateful
for whatever you have."
Right?
So she passed away December 12th, 2012.
And I remember 10 days after losing her,
I went to a job in Copenhagen,
and I already got the job before
and I didn't wanna cancel.
'Cause she wouldn't want me to cancel.
So I went to do the job,
but I told my agent,
don't tell them that I lost my mom.
I'm going there in and out,
and I'm coming out.
- Yeah, and it's easier if you don't
have to address it right then.
- Yeah.
So I got there in the morning,
and the lady was on her
computer, and she says,
"Oh, I had such a long, long, long day,
night I was shopping."
In my head I'm like, "You
complain about shopping."
And she said that her friend, oh my god,
her friend husband just got killed by,
he went for a run and a car hit him.
And they have three kids and
the oldest is 10 years old.
And so her friend can doesn't
even recognize where she is
and she doesn't want the
kids to go without Christmas.
- Oh my God.
- So that's why she was
doing the shopping.
- Oh, so you were thinking
like, "Oh, shopping's hard."
But then you don't really know
the whole story behind it.
- Yeah.
- Right.
- And that day earlier,
before I leave my hotel
and I never put TV on,
the TV was on, it was Obama
on TV crying about the Sandy-
- Mm.
- Sandy Hook.
- Mm hm.
- And he was crying talking about it
and just the fact that these
women put shoes of their kids
to take them to school and
they're getting a call.
Come pick up your dead like kid.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- And for me, I lost my
mom when I was older.
I had a job.
- Right.
- Made you grateful.
- I was already older.
- Yeah.
- I was like,
"Oh, this is what she meant.
You don't know what your
neighbors are going through."
- Yeah.
- Right.
- Because-
- Ooh, that realization.
- [Erin] I'm crying.
- Yeah, I am too.
- That's my mom.
- Yeah.
- And that's why
I keep telling people,
just be good to your parents.
- [Erin] She told me that.
- [Kelly] Yeah.
- I was in a fight with my mom actually
before all this happened,
- Yeah.
- and she's like, you don't understand,
don't do this.
- Don't do this,
don't do this!
Like just in life like, we
don't know we're gonna die.
Like that is like a universe rule.
We all know this is gonna happen, right?
- [Kelly] Mm hm.
- So what is the problem?
Like if we know we're gonna die,
then why we were so
hurt when they're gone?
It's because what we didn't say yesterday.
- Yeah.
- It's what they don't know
what we think of them, right?
Just tell people you love them,
and don't let your ego
get the best of you.
- [Kelly] Yeah, we take it for granted
that there is a tomorrow.
- Yeah, guys, we're so fragile.
Look what is the world
is going on right now.
- Yeah.
- Just be a good person,
and if you wanna tell someone (beep) you,
tell them (beep) you, but then-
(all laughing)
(audience clapping)
- But it doesn't have to go to violence.
- Yeah.
That's the thing. Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Well let's take a quick break.
Episodes of Season 14 of the
"Real Housewives of New York City."
If it's anything like,
just this conversation,
it's gonna be so intense.
I love it.
But they're now streaming on Peacock.
Y'all gotta go check that out.